- [Interviewer] Okay Alex.
Alex, where are you from
originally, where'd you grow up?
- Oh, Chicago, Illinois.
- [Interviewer] That's my town.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- [Alex] That's awesome.
- [Interviewer] And how
long have you been out here?
- [Alex] Exactly, October
10th, which is one year.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so you're
just, you're fairly new here.
- Right, exactly.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
You grew up with both parents, one parent?
- I grew up...
my parents were together
till about the age of like,
just about 10, and they separated.
My mom moved to New Jersey and
my dad went to Miami, Florida.
And I, you know, I was
upset with them, you know,
when they split and they
took me away from my friends,
so I kind of refused to
leave. So I stayed there.
- With who?
- My aunt.
And I just kind of bounced around
from Chicago to New Jersey to Miami.
Like when I caused enough trouble,
"I'm sending you to your mother's."
You know what I mean? (laughing)
When I'm go - causing enough
trouble "Oh, you're going
to your father's", you
know, I'd go to Chicago.
So it was just, I was
I was able to run wild
for a few years, you know
- Yeah, at 10 years old.
- Yeah. Well, until -
that went on for a while.
- And then after you went to high school?
- Yeah, I went to high
school, I graduated.
- And after high school where'd you go?
- That's where everything
kind of got a little wild
in my life. I went to
Miami and I met some family
I didn't know I had. Like
my mom, she did everything
she could my whole
childhood to keep me away
from like immediate uncles and stuff
I- and I didn't underst-
I was mad at first, but
then I realized why she wanted
to keep me away from them.
And then she realized
that, you know what I mean?
They couldn't do that anymore.
I mean, how is, how does it go?
Can I get in, do you want
me to tell you about that?
- Like how, when I met them?
- Yeah.
- It's actually wild story, man.
I was, I flew into Miami international.
I was like 17, 18, just
finished high school.
And I hadn't seen my dad in a few years,
and he picked me up from the airport.
Some guy's driving a Porsche cayenne
six hours late, picked me up.
So it was this guy
driving the car, there's
two girls in the car.
Later, find out they're
both strippers. My dad's
sitting in the back seat,
he's got a girl there.
There's a whole bunch of yayo
on the thing. And I'm just like,
Oh my God, this, you know, this is wow.
I was just going down
there to kind of get sober
and stuff, you know?
And I immediately saw,
that's not where this is going, right?
So we get to my dad's condo
in Sunny Isles Beach, Miami.
- So your dad did coke?
- Yeah. I mean, he was off the chain
and he was more like my
best friend, like a brother
like we partied, like, so
anyways, I walked into his condo.
I flipped the light switch on
all of a sudden, a hand comes
over my hand, knocks my hand
out of the way lights go down.
Two people pick me up. They
got bandanas over their face
slam me on the ground, pulled out a gun
put a gun in my mouth and
point the gun down like this.
And they're screaming at me punching me
hitting me all kinds of stuff.
And I just remember,
like, I'm sitting, laying
on the ground like this
and I can see my dad
and he's walking up the room
and like the last look like
I didn't say he just kind
of looks at me like this
and turned his head and
walked out the door.
And at that moment I was
like, I might die right now.
You know what I mean? Like
what's going on, right?
So they're, they're asking me questions
hitting me with the
gun, all kinds of stuff.
And next thing I know
another light comes on.
They take the things off
their face, pick me up
hug and kiss me. "How you
doing? I'm your uncle, Joey,
I'm your uncle, Jimmy. I'm
your, I'm your cousin, Joey."
And I'm like, what the fuck's going on?
- They were fucking with you
- And I was like, they wanted
to see what I was made out of.
Like, am I going to cry? Am
I going to go to the police?
Am I going to beg for my life?
You know what I'm saying?
Like, and I was just like
it was just so many emotions
came over me. It was like,
you know, and it was crazy.
And that's when man,
that was wild down there.
- I ended up in federal prison.
- For what?
- I just did like seven years
for a bank robbery. Unreal. Yeah.
- So your, your, your dad was doing coke.
- They're wild, yeah. He
was, he was off the chain.
My uncles he's dead now, but
he was connected down there
big time. I mean, I used
to ru- It was crazy.
- What age were you when you
first started using drugs?
- I was in rehab when I was 15
- 15?
15. I struggled, I struggled early.
I mean, it was Oxycontin when I was like
first time I shot, put a needle in my arm.
I was 14 years old.
- That was what?
And that was actually, my dad knew
- It was heroin?
Yeah. He didn't know I
was doing heroin but he had like
morphine one hundreds and Oxycontins
He would get me. And at first I was kinda
mad at him.You know what I mean?
Like inside, like I did
it with him, but like
I was kinda mad at him.
You know what I mean?
Cause I was like, I kind
of wanted subconsciously
I wanted him to tell me not to do it.
Cause it was like, that would
be proof that he loved me.
But then I thought maybe
he was giving 'em to me.
Cause he knew I would go out and get
it on my own and he wouldn't be around
So maybe he thought it was
safer? And so I kind of
just played these
scenarios over in my head.
You know what I mean? Why? And then I just
kinda realized that me
and my brother and sister
don't talk to him. They haven't
talked to him since they were little kids.
They refuse to, I mean, no
phone calls, there's no contact.
And it was like, he would do anything just
so he didn't lose, I guess the last person
in his family, maybe,
you know what I mean?
Cause it's like, my mom
doesn't talk to him.
Nobody. And it was like -
- You're the only one
that gets the connection.
- He know- That's my pops
though. I have a hundred
percent loyalty, you know
what I mean? It's my pops.
My girlfriend sleeps with her, with him.
She's the slut, she's gone. I don't care.
That's my dad. He can he can do no wrong.
- [Mark] : (laughing)
- You know what I mean?
Don't tell me otherwise,
you know what I'm saying?
That's my dad, I don't care.
And I think he took that and he used it.
He used it to get what he wanted.
He used it for his own addiction.
And I know he loves me
as best as he could.
You know what I mean? So
I mean one day I came home
and all of our stuff
is outside of the condo
and I'm like, what's going on, man.
He's like sweating,
drinking, drink, and drink
and drink and drink and drink and crazy.
And he drinks beer and
he pops pills, right?
So, but he's drinking the hard liquor
and I'm like, so something's
wrong. You know what I mean?
His dad drank a lot of hard liquor.
He beat the out of him
all the time. So he didn't
like hard liquor. He didn't
like me drinking hard liquor.
I could take morphine
and he was okay. But if I
drank hard liquor that was
a deal breaker, you know?
And I'm like, so what's going
on? Well, what are we doing?
Where are we going? The car pulls up and
he doesn't answer me. He's ignoring me,
and he gets in the car and he leaves,
you know what I mean?
With some of the stuff.
And I was basically on my
own. You know what I mean?
- What age are you at this point?
- 19. Oh man. And I
was banging out credit.
I was doing credit cards down there.
So I mean, basically I was on my own
at this point, Miami, Florida. And I
met somebody at the casino
and he had just done
I think 15 years in prison, his father
told on somebody. He
actually was the head of
Might be the Lucchese
family? Some, one of the
five families out on the
East coast, in New York.
His father actually ran it at one point
and then got in trouble, flipped and got
190 people indicted in federal prison.
190 people were indicted
because of this man
So he's in witness protection
program somewhere else, right?
And the son is this guy I meet
And I didn't know who he was at first.
And we were just doing a
little business here and there.
And then I realized that
just the way people look
at him and talk to him I'm like
Who is this guy? Is he in the movies?
You know what I mean? It's
like, he belongs in the movies.
I'm telling you, I mean,
he's off the chain.
And I learned who he was and he had
a hard life because of his
dad. You know what I mean?
And I feel we related a
lot and he taught me a lot.
I mean stuff that's gonna get you paid.
I mean, nothing that's
really gonna help you
out or help society, you know what I mean?
Just kind of contaminating everything.
But he was a good guy.
You know what I mean?
He looked out for me and the
bottom line is like I was fed
and I had a place to sleep
and I had money in my pocket.
You know, sometimes at
the end of the day, that's
that's all I'm going for.
You know what I mean?
It's like, I don't, I don't
want to do damage to people.
I just want to just want
to survive and be happy.
You know, just depending
on how you look at life
some people look at life
like they need money.
To me. My success is about
experience, memories,
knowledge. That's, what's important.
That's what's going to
matter. You know what I mean?
When I'm laying on my death bed
I don't want to look at my bank account.
I'm going to look back and say
Goddamn motherfucker, you went hard.
You gave it everything, you learned.
The good memories, bad
memories. It doesn't matter.
That's what it's about. You know?
- How old are you?
- Just turned 30.
- You're young still.
- It feels, I feel like
I'm young but I feel like I'm old too.
- How'd you get into bank robbing?
- It was, I got in, I
got in a little trouble.
I owed some, I owed some money.
I had a couple of prescriptions
and each one costs
like 2,500 bucks and I got them fronted
to me cause I was about
to go get rid of them.
I live with these three
girls, Kaylee, Roxie
and Lauren. One was from Dallas, Texas.
The other two were from
Little Rock, Arkansas.
I met these girls. They lived
in the same condo as my dad.
And I went out early one morning
and go smoke a cigarette.
And one of the girls has markers all
over her and it looks like she's sleeping.
And I kind of just walked
by and I laughed, was like
Oh, she had a wild night. And then I'm
hearing like a noise come out of her.
And I'm like, what the fuck is that noise?
And I looked and like her, her
cheeks are swollen and stuff.
And she's like moaning. And
I realized she got beat up.
Somebody beat her up, raped her.
And they drew all over
her like "Slut" this and
that, like, it was, it was fucked up.
And that's when I realized there was
something wrong with her.
And so I, I knew where her room was.
I didn't have a phone on me or nothing
So I just kind of picked
her up and I carried her
up to the room and I knocked on the door
and the girls were in the
room, frantic on the phone.
You can tell they're
all fucking coked up and
they're all, you know what I mean?
But they're like, looking
for her and I come
to the door and they
immediately hang up the phones.
Oh, we found her, we
found her this and that.
And that's how I became friends with them.
They, I mean, they were a wild bunch too.
They came, they came out to Hollywood,
Florida to get into the movies.
And I'm like, you girls
came to the wrong coast.
So basic, you know what I mean?
Girls come travel halfway
across the country
leave home to go end up in movies.
But where do they end up? In the titty bar
selling some ass, you know what I mean?
It's, it's inevitable. It
happened, you know what I mean?
It's it's like, and I ended up
living with them and
they were going to like-
man was an awesome time of my life.
I swear to God. I
remember one time I'm at,
I'm at the Jade off of Collins Avenue
like, penthouse all the way on the top.
And I got a bottle of Johnny Walker
blue label sitting there, a bucket of ice
rolling a blunt with some weed.
And I'm on the balcony
looking down at the ocean.
And I remember I turned my chair around
and I look inside and I used to go out
where they do private dances
so they don't get beat
up no more, like I kind
of just went on security.
Like not as like a pimp but like just as
their friend, you know what I mean?
And I kind of handled all
their financials for them
everything. Cause I mean,
they were off the chain.
They wanted to have fun, but
they're getting screwed over.
I mean, they were making so much money
but they were getting
screwed by everybody.
You know what I mean?
And when I came around
that stopped and we were just having fun.
Like they'd come home and
have $1,500 each that night.
So I'd go get an ounce
of coke, pound of weed,
Promethazine pills,
Xanax, go pay the rent.
Everything's handled. It's all beautiful.
You know what I mean? And we'd just run
around Miami like a wild bunch
but I'll never forget that night.
I turned around, you know
what I mean? I'm drinking
this whiskey, you know,
turn around and I look.
And these girls are giving these dances
in this room with these
like Russian mobsters.
There's like nothing in the whole room
except just like a couple
of couches, some boxes.
And that's it. And just
the lights were dim
The music was playing. I was like goddamn,
this life, you know,
it's like, I was happy,
but I got caught up in my addiction bad.
You know what I mean? And
that's what led to the
alleged bank robbers, bank robberies
I was indicted on like 16 or
17 of them in South Florida.
I was found guilty. Went to
federal prison. Did a few years
I got out of federal prison
October 1st last year.
Went out with my friends
that night, you know
to go celebrate, this and
that. Stepped outside after
hanging out with them for like an hour,
stepped outside for a cigarette
before my cigarette was
done, I already hailed a cab
got in the cab and left.
Didn't even say bye to
nobody or anything. I said
no, I'm not going to do this.
I called my aunt. I said,
Hey, can I stay by you
for a week and go work at the temp agency?
And I'll give you a- and
maybe, you know, you can
give me the money I worked for.
And you can go pick up my check and sign
for it over to yourself. And she's like
"Yeah, of course, no problem."
So I worked a week at the temp agency
bought my ticket out here and I had $258
left in my backpack. And
here I am a year later.
- So when you came to LA
for, did you have any-
- No, nothing.
- Just, Just came out here.
- Just came out here.
- And now you're on Skid Row.
- (scoffs) On Skid Row.
- [Mark] : (laughing)
- I'm everywhere.
- Where do you, where are you staying?
Where are you sleeping now?
- I try to stay in Santa Monica.
It's a little safer, you
know, I've done this.
I stayed down here in a
tent for a few months.
It's like, there's so
much bullshit, you know
there's, it's, but think
MacArthur Park's a lot worse
- Yeah
- You know, I come down here
I know which areas stay away
from, you know, it's like
I know what bullshit to
expect where down here
'Cause I've been down here so
long, or not even that long
but just I've gotten involved
in everything. You know?
And, but MacArthur park
is like that sleeping dog
you know what I mean? You never know.
- It's more dangerous.
- Yeah, 'cause it's the
most unexpected. They pulled
two bodies out of the water,
out of the lake right there this morning.
I'm watching that, you know. Last night
there's helicopters, there's eight squads.
They're holding some guy
down. He's just a white guy
in a suit laid down on the street. I mean,
I don't know what he did, but
they were on him, you know?
It's been a wild ride out here in LA.
My first two months I spent
running up and down the Hill
carrying batteries and
printers, making funny money.
I don't know if incriminated,
I'm not incriminat-
Yeah. There's no proof
of that. Allegedly, and
man, carrying batteries and cups of water.
And the guy I was working
with was a nut job.
He smoked so much
crystal. He'd- we'd do all
this work, it'd take a whole week. We get
everything almost done.
And all of a sudden,
I didn't know where, I'd smell smoke
and I'd be like, fuck, not again!
And I run out and there he
is burning everything we did,
All of our work, all
the money, everything.
Cause he had "They're
coming for us." He's been up
too many days. And after two months
of doing this, I mean we
were making good money.
Like we would come up,
but he would destroy
everything we built. Cause
he was whacked out of
his fucking mind. I mean, I would,
I would go down the hill
and go fill up like a
five gallon jug of water,
just so we'd have some
you know, for cooking
and drinking, everything.
And all of a sudden I hear the pops
and then be hearing shit
flying through in the bushes
as I'm coming up the hill and I'm like
I'm thinking like there's
rats or snakes going around,
And then I realized those were bullets
flying past me. This nut job up there.
Hears somebody coming
back up the mountain.
It's me. You dumb ass, you sent
me down for, 10 minutes ago
to go fill up this jug of
water. You know what I mean?
So I had to get out of there 'cause
that was an accident waiting to happen.
- Yeah
- You know what I mean?
But, that was wild.
- So, your dad is still around?
- Yeah. I haven't talked
to him in like six months.
I miss him. I love him. Yeah, I miss him.
- Where's your mom?
- Chicago or New Jersey.
- Do you talk to her?
- I haven't talked to
them in like six months.
I called my sister a week
ago and first thing she-
'cause I don't have a phone right now.
She's just like "Go to
the AT&T store right now.
I put you on my plan. You need a phone
so I can get in contact with you."
And I went to the AT&T
store and I needed an ID
and I haven't talked to them since.
I haven't talked to her since.
And I know I should, but I feel so guilty.
You know what I mean?
Because I should be there
because I love them more than anything.
But I don't because my habit is off the
fucking chain you know? I mean I'm like
I do Fe- I shoot and smoke Fentanyl.
- Is that your drug now?
- Yeah. Like your heroin doesn't do it.
- Yeah, so, that happens a lot
- And it's like $150 a
gram. I need at least
a gram to be functioning and
anything more, I'll be happy.
You know what I'm saying? Like my fence,
where I bring my stuff that I come up on
and they buy it from
me, she, she knows like
or used to be $20 will
fix me from being sick.
But $30 will make me smile.
Like there's no English, so it's
- So wait, what are you, what
are you selling a day now?
- What?
- How much do you
spend a day now?
- About 150, 200 a day.
- And what are you doing for money?
- I find things
- And resell
- Yes.
- Understood.
- Yup. Find things and resell them.
Not from people personally,
because I'm not a dirt bag.
I don't come up off of
people. But if it was like
a business or a company,
for some reasoning
I feel like that's the
lesser of the evils.
No, it's not right. But that's my reality.
- Something falls off the
truck and you find it.
- If you have a faster way
to make a hundred dollars
in two minutes, please
tell me because I'm, well
will be very open to that.
You know what I mean?
But it's like, I've tried the
working thing and it's like
by the time I'm done
working an eight hour shift,
I'm dope sick. And 'cause
me moving around so much
works all the drugs through my system.
And it's like, okay. I just
made almost a hundred dollars
for eight hours when I can
go walk into a store and
make a hundred dollars in 30 seconds.
I swear to God, you know? So it's like
And I've counted on that
to pay for some things.
So it's like, and now
I've been stuck into that.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I met these two girls
who went to USC and
they worked at the bars
down here in LA and I'd
go- they'd be slow and
she'd called me. I'd go over
there, hang out with them
Then she'd, you know, they'd
give me drinks and stuff.
And one day she walks by and she's like
pulls up a big stack of credit cards
And she's like, look at how
stupid people in LA are.
They forget all their stuff.
And I'm like, gimme,
gimme, gimme you know.
So I was making like $1,100
to $1,500 a week on that.
And all of a sudden she, she transfers.
She goes to study
abroad. And now I am like
thrown out into the jungle
with this monster habit
cause I'm making all this money
and I have no hustle now.
So what do I gotta do? I
gotta figure something out.
You know what I mean?
So it's been two months
I figured it, you know what I mean
I've, I'm sustained where
I'm comfortable that
I can count on it.
But I can also count on
the fact that I know my
days will be numbered because I know with
my lifestyle and this
fentanyl, I'm going to end
up in a box, whether that's
above ground or below.
- Yeah. You still look fairly clean.
- What?
- You still look
very- fairly clean.
- I try my best.
- You can pass for not being an addict
- Yeah, I know, If I go shower
and cleaned up, pull my hair
back, wear a cloth shirt
- Yeah, you'd fit in
Santa Monica perfectly
- That helps me fit into places
so I can do what I gotta do.
- Makes it easier, makes boosting easier
- You don't want to walk in
there looking like a fuck
'Cause then you're not they're
going to say get outta here
or watch you. You know what I mean?
So you kind of got to blend
in. I've learned, you know.
- You have kids of your
own, or anything like that?
- No, no kids,
- You stayed clear
of that, that's good.
- Yeah.
- And what's your, what's
your plan down the road?
Do you have any plans?
- I do. I need to get,
I need to figure out
what I'm going to do about my addiction
because it's like, I love
to get high. I love it.
Like I love getting high.
It's like a warm blanket on a cold night.
It's my happi- it's it's sad
to say, but it's my happiness.
And I need to figure out
a way to substitute that
with something else, because
I know I could be doing more.
I'm worth more. I'm wasting my life.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like, if there's a way
for me to balance this, my
first plan, my short, okay
My short-term goals. I need to
get into a methadone clinic.
I know methadone is not good but it's
the lesser of the evils. It's
gonna keep the needle out
of my arm and it's going to keep me out of
these stores doing dumb
shit. You know what I mean?
- Have you been clean before?
- Yeah.
- How'd you get clean?
- In prison, jail
- How horrible was that?
- Beyond, my, I mean detox
in a cell with some idiot.
You know what I mean? It's
like there's no, they don't,
- They don't care.
- Could you do it on your own?
- No, I couldn't. There'd
be no way, you can drop me
off in the desert or in a
jungle. Take away my phone,
my money, everything, cell
phone. And guess what?
I'm going to be high. I'm
going to figure it out.
- All right, man. Thank
you so much for coming by.
- All right, buddy.